I'm Caroline I am Jeffries how long have
you guys been friends for over here
all right what scares you the most
oh gosh
getting older and not like having
No
and in my mid-30s now that's scary
and spiders
what's your favorite memories with me oh
okay my favorite memory is when we
graduated from our yoga training
we sat upon the high dude with our
little strands of flowers and I felt
selected with you Oh like our souls were
like you know
very
what are you learning from me am i
learning from you know I guess just sort
of like
how to see other people with different
perspectives where they're coming
when you were my age you're my age what
scared you the mouth
[Music]
thirty-six so ah good what scared me to
mow
I wasn't going to find myself
I clearly
stop thinking about it a
and it terrifies me
and now in that I wish I could sell
myself just trust
everything
it's my new favorite thing that I
learned
[Music]
what do you remember from the first time
he met
oh goodness so it would have been the
first night of yoga training
and I remember being the only guy in the
tribe knows all these ladies
and I remember feeling drawn to you for
some reason
and I don't know why I felt drawn to you
and I felt drawn to Liz yeah huh and
then look at us now yeah I just remember
feeling very drawn you know and like
your energy of the questions you asked
the way you are special
[Music]
to be more
I found it more genuine and authentic
[Music]
the training it wasn't but something
about it was like
this one
this lady
you and a tough one yeah what's your
biggest regret
Wow
my biggest regret is not trusting my gut
seer
[Music]
and I was 15 I would never
today
but I feel like it's taking me along
like that
why me a son nobody wants regrets
yeah it's a good good thing to realize
[Music]
what are you hesitant to tell people
goodness
I am pretty open about my fears and my
self doubts and my insecurities being
vulnerable it's not difficult man I'm
hesitant to share with people the things
that are proud of cuz I don't want to
sound arrogant I don't want to come
across arrogant or
self-promoting or narcissism that I
think frightens me
that having that impact on people are
getting that impression
being self-deprecating good
what's your wildest dream my wildest
dream well these days it's to live like
a gypsy damn life yes we talked about
the van light with a surfboard and a dog
are you can have my dog and maybe it's
like travel the world like that and just
like trust that the money's gonna be
there yeah I just
that's my wildest dream but you can
borrow my dog okay he's a sweet
I don't understand about you
why
I don't think I could take something
because it's pretty intuitive
I feel like I'm pretty really hide much
I feel like anything I've shared with
you I mean you've always understood yeah
do you understand my ranch obsession on
everything people don't get that way but
I think while we ponder these yeah
that's so funny
[Music]
they feel satisfied
that was me yeah I just wanted to ask
you guys real quick to turn on the
notifications button on my channel right
next to the subscribe button is this
little bell if you click that you'll get
notified every time I put up a new video
that way you're not missing out
[Music]
[Music]